[Music]
it's been a minute since Michael Keaton
donned the cape and mask as Batman well
25 years to be exactly you know that was
sort of a huge undertaking at the time
it you know and those movies were hand
made compared to how how these movies
are made now he and learned this
firsthand
spider-man homecoming marks his return
to the superhero blockbuster only this
time he's the bad guy the world's
changing boys time we changed too
you played one of the greatest super
heroes of all time I played the
criticism that's right Batman is the
greatest but here you are as the villain
I mean was that a lot of fun for you
yeah yeah which do you prefer
I like them both you know they're
totally different this is you know fun
it's giant it's just a huge machine
that's rolling and you're just gonna
jump in there and become part of it when
you look at Tom in this movie and really
any of the actors in the Marvel films do
you think to yourself wow it's so
different to be a superhero these days
you know oh yeah totally it's totally
changed the look of this movie is very
very different from what Tim Burton and
we were all doing in and other people
kind of did after that it's much
brighter right now very bright very
bright
[Music]
you